nella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono falli j
lui è uno che non si fa i cazzi suoi e
questo gioco si chiama file ex file
eseguibile non so don't play play with
me va bene ai nostri tre quindi piraten
bar metcalf li [ __ ] non mi fa fine
di leggere bene a ma anche lei sta
facendo un gameplay ma come cazzo cose
che frena il gameplay quanto sei bella
zia c'è una mail le giovanili raven
chiocciola omelette ok bentornata a casa
sis storella però che il viaggio senato
bene ho sentito che ci vorrà molto buono
è una cagata saletta quindi non era
niente di che va bene andiamo su
internet a vedere i porno les paul even
questa roba non lo voglio cliccare cos'è
play.me soggiorno carlo zio da troppo a
questa è la finestra
se tu hai un albero morto con un buco in
mezzo breve mi si no
sì nel senso di no questa roba
ma che cazzo ma cos'è è un gioco del
genere tanto ormai ok mi piace qui non è
che me ne frega qualcosa ho davanti
che figata che c'è un gioco nel gioco
salve una volta ho visto uno scoiattolo
[Musica]
aspetta che ti mostro ischia che me ne
frega gesù cristo cosa cazzo vuol dire
come sono arrivato qui parlare non so
anche come sono arrivato io qui quindi
non ti preoccupare space and jump amica
quale parte i problemi dei ragazzi parte
progaming ma bisogna essere
professionisti del videogame pro basta
che palle un'ora di gioco mia ovvero
maya che il gatto va detto miao e che
non mi ha detto di aver visto uno
scoiattolo nomi chiara è tragico chiude
la finestra per continuare note hai
deciso di giocare al mio gioco non che
ci avessi dante alternativa è zio però
cosa da fare quindi
[Musica]
malaga chiazza che si è disputata una
roba ok
basta che palle 2 qual è il suo gioco se
dai ke kazzo questi alberi sono opposto
lamentosi quali alberi a questi bello a
questo quindi un albero e belli come
vuoi più belle e chic d'albero lo
scoiattolo era spaventato grazie a cazzo
ma che barbaccia e senza parlare degli
occhi e non fossile con quanto recita
diventando sto gioco basta suo gatto mia
ora adesso sta cambiando perché
attenzione che troppo parla anche video
lo scoiattolo un attimo è che ci mette
un po però anche lui lo vedo carico
pronti a vedere che succede al 3 2 1 non
capisco ma o che ha dato la foto che
tornata normale grazie a dio
semplice vero continua a giocare allora
del gioco e io ti dirò un segreto su me
stesso e se non me ne frega se veramente
un cazzo o internet che bello l'internet
è una roba satanica che non vinto la
dura perché non l'ho capita manco io
però è satanica ma l'albero tv è sparito
ma come come cazzo è sparito ladro ma
c'è un albero tentacolo forte fuori
molto peggio di quelli che vedono gli
enti
sorvoliamo
basta che palle ma anche come si chiama
questo gioco suocera punto exe
non lo so non me ne pento di ciò che ho
fatto nel cuore io si è preferito fare
un altro gioco preferivo giocare a
tetris lo scoiattolo com'era non volevo
ferirlo parete o sbagliato o salve un
giorno jolie sta diventando tutto punto
dimmi che cosa sta succedendo anzio
sociali dalla risposta stato mandati
melo miao miao cosa aggiunge adesso non
mi amiamo più grosso mia o grosso è il
mio grosso più grosso bene
j la finestra fammi vedere santana zia
quello è satana abitato nati pane che si
sposta che c'è il demonio in casa nella
continua a fare gameplay e monet graber
schifosa lo faccio per voi lo faccio
gioco col demonio in casa per voi
fantastico
ti prego iddio vasta che tortura e ai
testicoli troveranno mai vallo spero
anch'io di ma la strada appare il
campeggio ruspa
non vogliamo i clandestini questo è
subito scagliato lo striato come lo
scoiattolo di merda tu e il tuo
scoiattolo del cazzo ha veramente
interrotto la sacca palla ce a ok sono
curiosi di che cosa mi dirai gatto
ragazzi sempre più senza parole questi
animali è diventato un quarantenne di
facebook il gatto non seguendo vai è
sempre meglio vedi a truccarsi troppo
che succede credo che tu voglia sapere
il mio nome
la verità è che ho tanti nomi quindi non
posso dire soltanto uno per adesso puoi
chiamarmi file
ciao file di oggi che fai mamma mia che
batte iscrivetevi al canale di fa vige
tv che merita un sacco una cosa devo
fare adesso è finita il codice morse non
ho mai avuto sbattiti imparavo nella
vita reale lo dove imparare in un
videogioco ma sucate mi sembra la sacca
palla ce non ho capito non grazie
dell'interessamento ma no mamma la mia
mail mi ha appena vomitato un pesce
vediamo ordinare su just eat dai
ristoranti scadenti
[Musica]
l'ho fatto
li ho uccisi tutti stavano cantando
nelle loro lacrime
[Musica]
grazie a dio 6 squartato perché se mi
parlavi ancora di scoiattoli te li
facevi ingoiare delizioso e non mi sa
che se magna dello scoiattolo vabbè poco
male pentiti ben ricordati che devi
morire pentiti sono più venduto tutto
perduto io fa male è solo prendi alcuno
zio fa malissimo ricordati ricordati
cosa che devi morire
ricordati che se schiacciate un ufo
gatto dimmi che ricordati che devo
morire non c'è più il gatto al posto del
gatto c'è una fabbrica di androidi
c'era da aspettarselo credo permesso kg
la finestra continua ma stavolta non è
successo niente di strano
ok ma che la divina commedia ma gli
animali ma neanche io non è il ragazzo
ma neanche io perché va bene non hai la
macchina anche mancini non ci mancava
dente non hai un lavoro aver neanche io
facevo youtube
haier a spendere così tanto tempo su to
computer è effettivamente lo faccio per
voi
hai lasciato la tenda aperta la finestra
[Musica]
perché quel dito sembra un pene va bene
non spengono spengo zio tranquillo
pronti incazzare dopo cliccare qua ok
non spengono però dimmi cosa lo fa o sei
credo che di essere dentro la fabbrica
di cioccolato non la fabbrica degli
androidi prima probabilmente rame
ok cosa ci devo fare qui dentro per me
le salve non ci arrivi
loro sono dovuti andare dove sono andati
inspiegabili oddio sono era che cos'è ci
sono anche un campo rom è diventato
quello questa roba non è che se mangi
uno scoiattolo automaticamente diventi
la morte con la falce però ok 30 maggio
scoiattoli
ma ahimè ex crass sapete che vi dico
prova a scriverlo veramente su un sito
che decifra il codice binario voglio
vedere cosa mi esce fuori
ok vediamo to text mi è uscito fuori
non so se si legge morte
auguri anche a te famiglia mi è uscito
fuori ancora una morte fantastico salve
grazie degli auguri di buona pasqua
anche a lei
vabbè però dovevo dovevo decifrarlo in
codice binario perché non sicuro che
volesse dire qualcosa ma se jason
chiedono di venerdì 13
c'è anche una salsiccia perché per
quelli che la madonna mi già sta
diventando un platform e ragazzi cos'è
sta roba
porca vacca di protetta serve voglio
andare a casa anche io in questo momento
però posso vederti
[Musica]
non è vero stai mentendo 4 fac
quindi ragazzi questa era la prima parte
di file punto ex ci sarà anche la
seconda parte che sarà molto più strong
della prima dichiara finalmente chiudo
un video senza il pigiama c'è una cosa
in carriera voci sono la migliore sotto
il pigiama niente rai che non ci avevo
voglia di divertirmi ha messo sulla fede
quindi ragazzi spero capitolino ci sia
perfetto sconosciuto momento mi piace
anche ai vari stato compiuto dalla
sezione sensi si siete riuscito il
diavolo fosse un video belle ragazze
[Musica]